in honor of may the fourth we talked to
one of the most adored characters in the
star wars franchise
her name is kendra doll and she played
one of the beloved ewoks
in star wars episode six return of the
jedi
may the fourth be with you kendra hello
hello and may the force be with you as
well mercedes
it is so good to have you on so many
star wars fans here in studio are so
excited that you're joining us now
tell us a little bit about how you got
the role of an ewok in return of the
jedi it was a casting call from what i
understand
do you did you know what you were
auditioning for at the time
um what happened was i had done a
picture before
with the same casting people um and they
had done a
show with many little people in it quote
unquote little people
and so they reached out again to the
little people
community that they knew um from that
movie and then we kind of had to
audition we kind of they kind of had to
know a little bit about us
um but it was all mostly through the
platform of the little people of america
organization
that this all happened but when i went
to do the movie we had no idea it was
star wars
they tried to keep everything really
hush-hush they were just saying it was
some kind of horror film called blue
harvest
um and and there was like this little
saying was
something wicked this way comes and
you know people were guessing that it
was star wars but no one was really sure
until we were all of a sudden starting
to see the principles coming to work
um and and then it was like okay we know
that is it was really fun so amazing now
i hear you had a
an interesting um meet up with some of
the cast members while you were having
lunch one day kind of
awkward intimidating moment when you had
lunch on the set what happened
um it was my first date because i
actually flew to california from
oklahoma
and um i was going to do my fitting for
my costume because everything had been
done
through the mail drawings measuring you
know sending in measurements and sending
traces of my hands and things like that
so they wanted to try on the costume for
actual size
um so they were starting with the
fitting and of course while you're in
that costume for a very short time you
get all sweaty and gooey
and then they said you know what we're
gonna do another uh take with the
costume
after lunch they're breaking for lunch
and we'll have you meet george lucas so
you can see how you look and i thought
oh my god
so anyways um so i go to lunch and they
just have this big
tent covered covering with picnic tables
everywhere
and everyone's already there because i'm
you know i had to take all that stuff
off and with the helpers of the dressers
and i walk in there and there's just i
have a plate full of stuff and there's
nowhere to sit
and no other little people were there
yet there weren't the ewoks weren't on
set yet
and mark hamill said i'll give you my
seat here
you know and there i am in the midst of
carrie fisher harrison ford
peter mayhew you know and i recognized
carrie right away because i had worked
with her before
in the movie under the rainbow right not
intimidating at all to have it was
princess leia right there
kendra that is so amazing
thank you for taking the time to talk to
us on this may the 4th we
appreciate it so much and las vegas now